in Potsdams bester Lage direkt an der
Havel befindet sich der Sportplatz des
ESV Lokomotive doch nach über 70 Jahren
droht dem Traditionsverein Ungemach denn
der Eigentümer die Bundesbehörde
eisenbahnvermögen will das Gelände zum
Höchstpreis verkaufen der Verein hat
Angst dass sich Immobilienunternehmer
das Filetgrundstück unter die Nagel
reißen
der kann doch nicht von
Immobilienmaklern verhöckert werden das
kann doch nicht zugelassen werden
politisch nicht gesellschaftlich nicht
ist Sportstätten werden gebraucht und
das dann eine Bundesbehörde sagt dass
Sie nicht bereit sind im Preis
runterzugehen und das Maximalgebot haben
wollen ist wie man sagt ein skandala
seit 1951 hat der ESV Lokomotive hier
seine Heimat inzwischen mit 1.300
Mitgliedern schon seit 20 Jahren
versucht der Verein den Platz zu kaufen
doch es gibt einen Dauerstreit mit der
Bundesbehörde mit den Grundstückswert
inzwischen setzt ihm das
Bundeseisenbahnvermögen bei 5,6
Millionen Euro an und will nur zum
Höchstgebot verkaufen viel zu teuer für
den kleinen Verein für Immobilienfonds
aber wäre das ein Klacks der
ehrenamtliche Vorstand hat Angst um die
sportliche Heimat ich weiß nicht was
jemanden treibt zu sagen es muss
unbedingt eine riesen Summe zustande
kommen und da
Ignoranz
der Umstände die es hier sind Woche für
Woche sitzen wir und machen uns Gedanken
wie wir uns hier am Leben erhalten
können und werden auch von dieser
Behörde gedrehten und schikaniert
und das schlimmste finde ich ist es geht
eigentlich hier nur ums Geld jetzt hat
das Bundesverkehrsministerium das
Verfahren an sich gezogen versucht zu
vermitteln damit das Gelände im Eigentum
der öffentlichen Hand bleibt zurzeit
werden zwischen der Landeshauptstadt
Potsdam den Bundeseisenbahnvermögen und
den Bundesministerium für digitales und
Verkehr Möglichkeiten einer für alle
Beteiligten rechtlich und wirtschaftlich
gangbaren Lösungen erörtert
die Mitglieder haben aber weiterhin
große Sorge dass ihr schöner Platz mit
Willen zugepflastert wird die Kinder
waren sich jetzt natürlich auch Sorgen
und Fragen uns dürfen wir denn überhaupt
weiterspielen wenn es verkaufen das darf
so eigentlich nicht passieren und das
ist auch für Kinder Vereine Jugendliche
die total falsche Botschaft den Verein
läuft die Zeit davon Ende 2025 läuft der
Pachtvertrag aus bis dahin muss geklärt
sein dass hier weiter gekickt werden
darf